It is time for YouTube Awards.
YouTube Awards.
The Academy of Television Arts
and Sciences announced last week
-they will be expanding
their, uh, categories -Oh!
to allow online content creators
to be awarded Emmys.
Because the Emmys
aren't long enough! Uh...
Stretch it out
over two broadcasts.
So now all your PewDiePies
and your Damn Daniels
can have an opportunity
to win one of these!
Mwah. Oh, man.
Mmm. Oh, it feels so good.
-Oh.
-(cheering and applause)
Mmm. So nice.
This is a little factoid.
Um, the-the hardest award
to fit in another person,
uh, the Emmy. The Emmy.
Comedians,
I would like you to give me
as many YouTube-specific
Emmy categories as you can
in 60 seconds. And begin!
Nikki Glaser.
Loudest "Hey, Guys!"
Points!
That was goddamn amazing.
Doug Benson.
Uh, Most Incoherent Complaint
About the Female
Ghostbusters Movie.
Points. Kyle Kinane.
Salvia's Greatest Knockouts.
Points. Doug Benson.
Saddest Bedroom.
Points. Nikki Glaser.
Uh, Best Prank to Shatter
the Trust in a Marriage.
Points. Doug Benson.
Best Talk Show Where the Guests
Get High with Doug Benson.
-(cheering)
-Kyle.
Best Fight at a Family Barbecue.